[Musik]
ich glaube einer wird sterben ich glaube
auch heute das hat ich habe kein gutes
gefühl
[Musik]
machen wir getrennt wir sagen heute
nicht wie folgender planen wir
aktualisieren um 16.30 den kanal von
morgen gucken dann opfers veröffentlicht
wurde
und falls jahren wollen einfach nur eine
spende entscheiden einfach mit münzwurf
wäre es ist der stift
beginn 10 sekunden
ja okay im fall besprochen unserer blog
abhalten
[Musik]
wie kommen sie mit uns
nein
[Musik]
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
folge war o 4
es sieht schlecht aus leute glaube wir
werden sterben wie leute folgen der plan
bei mir war direkt vor der nase müssen
um ok muntari und bei luca waren auch
direkt welche vor der nase wir gehen mal
davon aus dass auch die beiden sind max
und ich waren relativ nahe beieinander
zum ende der letzten folge und jetzt
wollen wir halt warten bis die anderen
vom server runter sind dann ganz schnell
drauf schauen oder wieder weglaufen weil
ihr kennt ja unsere folgen eigentlich
hauen wie die ganze zeit nur ab so leute
es ist gleich 16 30 minister morgan und
ari nicht jetzt im moment eine folge
veröffentlichen dann dürfen sie okay ist
es 16 30 aktualisiere und wir sollten
darauf können wir sollten darauf können
wir können auf luca okay ich hab
geträumt ich hab geträumt max ich hab
geträumt ich auch nein ich bin in einer
falle ich bin in der falle
wo bist du ich bin in einer falle nein
ich bin in der falle
ok gebaut ich merke es ist ja keiner
nach geträumt ja morgen
ich betone ich bin tot ich bin so gut
ich bitte dich getroffen
nein luca luka ich bin schon ich betone
ich bin so gut ich mit nein
[Musik]
nein gar nicht aufnehmen
dies stimmt die dürfen nicht aufnehmen
die haben mich getötet oder hat arrivas
veröffentlicht mister x games auch auf
dem server ist scheißegal
die dürfen nicht aufnehmen okay ich bin
anscheinend fälschlicherweise
rausgeflogen ok wird wird checken das
nochmal und luca wird euch bestimmt mal
einblenden ob es stimmt ob wir recht
hatten
aber falls das fälschlicherweise
geschehen ist dann vier folgen
man darf maximal drei im voraus
aufnehmen okay leute das war ja alles
relativ unklar ihr merkt vielleicht dass
ich gerade aus dem schnitt zurück
spreche es gab da viele viele
unklarheiten aber das allerwichtigste
ist luca ist rechtmäßig gestorben und
luca kommt auch nicht irgendwie wieder
zurück oder sowas in warum allerdings
gibt es noch einige sachen die man
erklären muss und die halt wirklich
unklar waren während der gesamten
aufnahme und der verwehrt ich immer mal
wieder aus dem schnitt irgendwie zu euch
sprechen um euch sachen zu erklären oder
einfach weiß sachen gesagt habe die
falsch waren
um die seit auszublenden und ja soviel
dazu erstmal bitte ihr habt ihn ein
ok ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade
aufgenommen habe ich beende das man ja
alles gerade ganz kurz und check dass
man eben alles als ich bin jetzt vom
server runter wir sehen uns vielleicht
wieder alter luca du bist ja bei mir
noch dabei war
ich bin noch auf dem server gleich
problem irgendwie abzuhören ich muss das
mal gerade alles checken
also ich bin gerade komplett alleine
irgendwo die frage ist ob man
rechtzeitig noch veröffentlicht hat
tatsächlich alter schwede wir waren so
nah beieinander wieder ne also zur frage
ob man rechtzeitig veröffentlicht hat
nein das hat er nicht und er hat dafür
eine strafe bekommen eine ziemlich harte
strafe und zwar wurde er von waro
ausgeschlossen ich erkläre euch erstmal
die gesamte
story und zwar die ausgangslage war
man darf nur drei folgen im voraus
produzieren war ist ja vor produziert
das ist ja kein geheimnis
und es sind halt maximal drei folgen die
man im voraus produzieren darf bis der
morgen und sein team partnerin hatten
halt drei folgen vorproduziert und
deshalb haben wir uns halt im sicheren
gewogen dachten okay wir können auf den
server die dürfen nicht mehr aufnehmen
und deshalb sind wir halt sicher der
entscheidende fehler den wir gemacht
haben ist dass wir nur gewartet haben
bis mo runter war aber seinem
teampartner die irgendwie fünf sekunden
später geträumt war wahrheit als luca
auf den server kam noch drauf und konnte
ihn somit rechtmäßig töten
okay luc also jetzt ganz ohne dich muss
sie gerade irgendwie mein überleben
kämpfen
okay man sieht in der gruppe musste
morgen ist vor drei minuten geräumt
ja ja ja genau er aber wie so erzählt er
denn dann irgendwelche sachen von wegen
hätte es nicht gemacht
so leute und genau das ist nämlich der
springende punkt aus diesem grund wurde
man dann letztendlich ausgeschlossen aus
marl haltern im anschluss gelogen hat
als es darum ging die ganze sache zu
klären und deshalb diese strafe für ihn
junge ich kämpfe so übers ums überleben
weil ich wollte dich ja unbedingt retten
und habe dafür allein mein essen
verraten dass ich irgendwie zu dir finde
ich verstehe jetzt nicht was los ist
ich bin rausgeflogen aus dem projekt
obwohl ich nicht von den leuten obwohl
ich nicht hätten auf dem server sein
dürfen wie gesagt wussten wir nicht dass
ari hatte drauf sein dürfen und es ist
halt alles absolut richtig so ja aber
das wird ja noch geklärt falls du
tatsächlich unrechtmäßig gekühlt wurde
es dann ist es ja einfach nicht in
ordnung wenn man nicht rauswirft leider
war es recht mäßig max weil also er
steht in den regeln der tod ist
unwiderruflich echt
er hat wenig gerade geschrieben
also was wir jetzt machen passiert
eigentlich in der ganzen restlichen
folge auch wir diskutieren irgendwie
darüber ob das ganze rechtmäßig war
ich habe sie jetzt alleine schon aus dem
oft noch drei mal gesagt dass alles
rechtmäßig war
aber wie gesagt ja also wir haben da
halt sehr sehr viel darüber diskutiert
weil logischerweise luca war gerade raus
und dann haben wir uns halt sehr dafür
interessiert ob das alles in ordnung war
und irgendwie sind wir dover weise auch
noch davon ausgegangen dass mister more
dinkel gemacht hat ich weiß nicht
irgendwie für mich persönlich ging das
alles irgendwie so schnell dass ich gar
nicht in den chat geguckt haben gesehen
habe dass ari da war ich habe nur sein
ok mister magic server luca ist tot
und dann dachte ich irgendwie okay
martin gekillt und das ganze war nicht
rechtmäßig wir wussten auch während der
ganzen aufnahme nicht dass ari das ganze
recht mäßig das haben wir erst im
nachhinein aus gefunden ok jetzt
schreiben gerade in die gruppe a rhi hat
geschrieben ist am ort seine folge
öffentlich gestellt bevor neu gedeutet
ich habe geschrieben laut youtube nicht
nein hat er nicht ari zombie die wahl
noch nicht freigeschaltet
da hat sich dann halt herausgestellt
dass mister more den fehler gemacht hat
und dass wir im nachhinein versucht hat
ihnen irgendwie zu vertuschen und das
war letztendlich wie gesagt der grund
für seinen rauswurf nicht dass er
einfach zu früh getrennt ist und noch
eine folge aufgenommen hat also es wäre
einfach wirklich schade falls das jetzt
der das ende von team auf sein sollte
nichtsdestotrotz falls der ausgang so
ist dann muss man das irgendwie
akzeptieren
aber es wäre sehr sehr sehr schade so
ich kann einfach mal die zeit nutzen um
euch ein paar allgemeine informationen
zu geben und zwar wird war auf meinem
kanal weiter gehen und nicht nur das
sondern auch schon gesehen minecraft
maut das ist ein projekt dass luca und
ich uns in anschluss an war überlegt
haben einfach weil es so viel spaß
gemacht hat irgendwie zusammen minecraft
aufzunehmen und ihr habt schon sehen 22
12 da wird es kommen zu minecraft maus
will ich jetzt noch gar nicht so viel
sagen aber erstmal zu war luca kann ja
immer noch mitreden und ich würde echt
gern mal von euch wissen wollt ihr dass
ich alleine die changes noch weitermache
das heißt luca geht medigene ist und ich
mache das ganze alleine oder worauf habt
ihr bock christin gerade welche geträumt
mein tod wäre auf jeden fall unentdeckt
war wenn jetzt jemand mich tötet denke
ich mal
ok also ich selbst hätte auf jeden fall
echt bock auf changes aber irgendwie
will ich auch ein bisschen action weil
alleine macht halt einfach nicht so viel
spaß sag ich mal wie im team da die
ganze zeit herum zu hoffen und ab zu und
sage ich mal
schreiben gerade es ist auf jeden fall
ein streik für morgen gott hier ist eine
höhle von jemandem den ich gehe lieber
nicht rein wobei dann könnte ich halt
auf die höhe
ok schreiben gerade man kann nicht
absichtlich einen strike in kauf nehmen
niemand zu töten das ist ein rausschmiss
ich knüpfe jetzt einfach mal immer
wieder hier an wenn ich quasi nach
kommentiere eine sache die ich natürlich
machen könnte die sich gewissermaßen
auch anbieten würde wäre sich irgendwie
mit ari zu verabreden also mit der team
partnerin von mister morgen und mit der
hat irgendwann was wann zu machen oder
so ich glaube die haben dadurch dass wir
uns jetzt eigentlich von der ersten
folge an gejagt haben auch nicht so dass
über equipment aber ja es habe natürlich
auch viele geschrieben
ihr habt noch nicht mal für einen oder
sowas es ist ja auch nicht ganz so
leicht wenn man von der ersten folge an
verfolgt wird also es ist halt schon ein
bisschen bisschen schwierig gewesen sage
ich mal bei uns dieses war aber
vielleicht ist ja nicht das letzte
gewesen
ich renn halt einfach gerade nur noch
also auch wenn du wieder belebt wird bin
ich halt drei kilometer weg aber ich
weiß nicht ob der tod ist unwiderruflich
bin draußen quasi mein alter ich erkläre
euch jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen was
ich da im gameplay eigentlich mache und
zwar hatte ich ja kein essen mehr und wo
ich war waren halt einfach sich gegner
und jetzt da ich halt alleine war was
noch meine nummer gefährlicher als mit
blue card zusammen und dann bin ich
einfach abgehauen
auf der suche nach essen und hab halt
irgendwie mich in der ganzen gegend mal
umgeschaut ob ich keine ahnung was
brauchbares finden oder so was aber vor
allem war ich halt noch so ein bisschen
verwirrt sage ich mal interpad nebenbei
mit luca irgendwie diskutiert wie es
jetzt weitergeht und na ja wie soll ich
sagen das geht halt für mich einfach
jetzt erstmal weiter ja also dieses war
echt extrem viel spaß gemacht muss ich
sagen diese ganze change geschichte hat
es extrem aufgewertet es gab da ja auch
kritik auch aus den aus den reihen der
ware mitspieler aber nichtsdestotrotz
finde ich einfach das hat echt
aufgewertet hat mir spaß gemacht mit den
challenges und ja ich bin der meinung
dass man so was auf jeden fall noch mal
machen kann und das ist eigentlich auch
vielleicht so ein kleiner bereicherung
für das projekt war
auf jeden fall leute diese change ist
absolut hals über kopf diese change von
diese folge und ich würde gerne mehr
kommentieren oder sowas aber es ist
einfach einfach ein bisschen zu
abgefragt was gerade hier passiert und
ich unbeschädigt auszudrücken
hier war anscheinend noch keine so ich
werde mal zu sehen dass ich mir
irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht wie viele
aufnahmen zeit ich noch habe schon noch
ein bisschen sich zumindest mal fallen
wäre das wird jetzt nacht leute mir
gehen wir also ein bisschen die nach
kommentiert teile sage ich mal aus und
vielleicht verrate ich euch noch ein
bisschen mehr über minecraft muss also
was soll ich sagen 22 zwölfter das
könnte ich auf jeden fall merken und ich
glaube jetzt einfach ab und zu mal
informationen also als allererstes es
werden abwechselnd folgen auf den
kanälen von mir und luca erscheinen auch
weiss ist jetzt irgendwie heißt so
youtube hat es nicht veröffentlicht oder
sowas
das steht dann denk ich mal ihren frei
ob er das glauben möchte oder nicht
aber auch falls youtube erst später
veröffentlicht hat er muss ja selbst
schauen wann es öffentlich zugänglich
ist für alle weil das wahrheit für uns
eine sicherheit also wir sind ja davon
ausgehen dass wir absolut sicher sind
weil sie noch nicht veröffentlicht haben
und dass wir uns halt ohne probleme
entfernen können an der stelle noch mal
mister mord seine strafe bekommen und
hat ein gesehen also bitte bitte geht
nicht zu ihm und hechtet ihn irgendwie
dass wir recht unnötig dankeschön
okay man erstmal fahren in folge 45 grad
nicht viel
folge 5 sowie das gar nicht so viel
kommentiere aber er mich macht das
gerade einfach nur fertig ja ich
verstehe ich versteh's absolut luca also
ich mach dir keine vorwürfe
man kann nicht mehr sagen als dass ich
es sehr verstehen
allein hat hier keine chance ich sagte
jetzt dass ihr allein keine chance also
meine chancen sind wahrscheinlich
wirklich sehr begrenzt dass ich allein
minecraft wahl gewinne aber das heißt ja
nicht dass wir nicht noch ein paar
spannende folgen hinkriegen also ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass wir ein
zwei kämpfe führen vielleicht gewinne
ich ja so langkamp es gibt ja noch
andere einzelkämpfer sage ich mal
und da könnte ich auf jeden fall drauf
freuen aber um mal wieder die brücke zu
minecraft auszuschlagen
wir werden höchstwahrscheinlich mit
einem mod pack spielen und was auch noch
eine sehr wichtige information ist dass
es ein sehr sehr limitiertes projekt
wird wir werden nämlich davon nur zehn
folgen machen also sie müssen die
mussten ja quasi die ganze zeit gerade
gewartet haben bis wir zu ihnen bin ich
schon auf der einen seite krass so dass
man so viel zeit darin investiert auf
der anderen seite natürlich auch respekt
das natürlich schon heftig wie man
seinen alltag danach richten kann
perfekt ja nee also muss muss ich auch
sagen großen respekt vor allen leuten
die bei war aus meppen und sowas ist
schon schon in gewisser weise
respektabel
weil es einfach wahnsinn ist wie viel
zeit da reingesteckt wird den perfekten
moment zu erwischen so leute das war's
jetzt erstmal zu minecraft maut ich
hoffe mal dass euch diese folge
irgendwie trotzdem gefällt gerade weil
es war halt für mich sehr wichtig dass
ich keine falschen informationen teile
zu der geschichte mit moor und deshalb
habe ich das getan hier waren wir jetzt
mal ein bisschen finstern ich hoffe
einfach mal das vielleicht ein paar
gegner noch keinen bogen haben und ich
dann dadurch ein bisschen vorteile habe
aber die nicht sollte auch gekickt
werden noch nicht ich der gekickt wird
das ich noch den ofen abbauen
damit hält nichts von mir rum liegt
[Musik]
ein bisschen angst gekriegt werde und
was sag ich mal übrig lasse jetzt habe
ich auf jeden fall schon mal eine menge
pfeile 29 kann man schon mal was
anfangen
falls es so weit kommt dass ich
irgendwie kämpfen muss leute also es ist
erschreckend in summe
es ist alles ungewiss nichts ist gewiss
so will ich die folgen falls sich nicht
klickt werden würde ich mich jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen hier weiter ich öffne
mein koordinaten mal nicht auch wenn ich
absolut keine ahnung habe wo ich mich
gerade in bewegung
ich würde ja gerne irgendwie so in der
lage sein uns als team zu rechnen
aber leider bin ich nicht so im training
das ich im können welchen teams
aufnehmen könnte falls ihr es denn
jemals war
hier gibt's auf jeden fall mal jede
menge essen glaubt ab sofort weil die
unter der erde leben
ja ich mir ich werde gleich mit xcom
zucker raum dass man sich noch
also leute das ganze wird jetzt geklärt
sorry für die komische folge wir wären
reduziert mit geringst habe es ist nicht
schlimm